le spoutnik v pourrait-il être le
prochain vaccin autorisé dans l'union
européenne
la m a lancé le processus d'homologation
du sérum russe et si le régulateur donne
son approbation
moscou se dit prêt à fournir des doses
pour près de 50 millions d'européens dès
juin lieux qu'ils estiment pouvoir
vacciner l'ensemble de ses habitants
d'ici la fin de l'été la situation sur
les vaccins et rassurante
c'est un défi énorme et pourtant nous
avons réagi avec une grande rapidité
j'ai extrêmement confiance dans la
capacité de l'europe à livrer les
vaccins plus rapidement et je pense que
d'ici la fin de l'été nous pourront
vacciner tous les citoyens européens
face aux retards qui se multiplient dans
l'union européenne
plusieurs pays d'europe centrale se sont
déjà tournés vers le spoutnik v la
hongrie a été la première à inoculer le
vaccin russe à sa population suivi par
la slovaquie et la république tchèque
qui commencent à recevoir leur première
dose du sérum d'abord accueilli avec
méfiance par lieu spoutnik v n'a rien à
envier aux vaccins déjà approuvé par l'
agence européenne des médicaments
selon vladimir poutine nous avons de
quoi être fier notamment du fait que
notre vaccin nos vaccins sont les plus
sûrs et efficaces dans le monde entier
j'ai déjà cité les données que vous me
connaissez sans doute bien
astrazeneca est une très bonne société
qui produit un très bon vaccin dont le
niveau de protection et de 61%
celui d'une autre et de 91,6 % cependant
rien n'est encore acté si moscou se
tient prêt à fournir des doses aux
européens bruxelles souligne que la
validation du vaccin russe par le
régulateur européen se basera sur des
critères sanitaires et non géopolitique
je voudrais dire très clairement que
l'aem entreprend son analyse d'un vaccin
sur des critères sanitaires liés à la
fiabilité l'efficacité du vaccin point
final il n'y a aucune autre
considération que celle là et par
conséquent la géopolitique n'a rien à
voir avec le fait que la même considère
si un vaccin est fiable et
kick ass ou non car cela se fonde sur
l'évaluation du vaccin
pour l'heure seuls trois vaccins sont
autorisés par l' agence européenne des
médicaments ceux de pfizer moderna et
astrazeneca ce nouvel examen intervient
alors que le nombre de nouveaux cas de
coved 19 dans l'union européenne ont
augmenté de 9 % en une semaine